good morning believe nation today's
message is you have the right to be here
over to you Barbara Corcoran when I was
a kid and was such a stupid kid in
school I was made to feel stupid i
learned shame in the classroom reading
out loud what a wonderful background to
be an entrepreneur you know what I
learned by the time I got I that goddamn
a schoolhouse which I called jail hmm
you know what I have the right to make
place for myself and so for the next so
many years of my life I just thought I
have the right to be here that was my
attitude I have the right to be here so
if I walked into room filled with men's
suits and they ignored me and I
introduced myself and they kept talking
I stood there and said the same thing
myself again you you know what I have
the right to be here I have the right to
be here it was a self pumping up but you
want to know the idea that I had the
right to be anywhere I got me into the
elevator got me publishing a bad report
on Donald Trump which got me invited
into his huge disk where he looked down
at me got me in more hot water because I
got in the habit of going through the
door and you want to know what I have
learned about myself and what I have
learned about every great salesman or
entrepreneur ever worked with if you can
get in the habit of going through the
door without the answer in our education
system tends to make you want to have
the answer if you walk through that door
people are amazingly smart once you're
in there in hot water you discover the
answer every time I could discover the
answer on my feet that I didn't have
outside the door I don't have you heard
a couple years back there was a
maintenance guy who rescued a boy of a
track of a subway train ready to run
them over he jumped in and rescued the
kid and when he was interviewed for the
whole week and given the key to the city
you know he said I didn't know it was a
hero he was a hero right I have found
walking through every door believing
that I'm going to go through the door
jump out the window i'm going to learn
how to fly on the way down and you want
to know i have always had my best
successes and so I wholeheartedly
believe in the belief that all of us
have the right to be there as for what
we want we all can be rich week
all put our dagger in the sand whatever
that thing is called and say that's me
I'm going for it what the heck and I
don't think it's a reserved right for
anybody and that attitude has been more
responsible for building my business in
my career than any other thing this is a
really important topic because we all
have these limiting beliefs we always
lemonade mindsets and we talk ourselves
down from things we talk ourselves out
of things right we have these brief
moments of boldness where we think we
can do anything and then we wake up the
next day feel like I can't do that Who
am I to do that I don't have the right
to be here and we come up with excuses
like I don't have the right education or
I don't have the right family
connections or you know I don't have the
right experience I don't have the right
friends I don't live in the right
country you know whatever it is and
that's going to hold you back to the
rest of your life until you realize that
it's it's it's a limiting belief and so
the key to combating limiting beliefs is
one awareness awareness is always a
first step but i think it's the hardest
step you know I've an entrepreneur
friend of mine who is convinced that
because of his education he's not good
enough and and he doesn't realize how
much that holds him back and it comes
across so many times and how he talks
and that because I don't have this
education that's why he's not successful
has nothing to do with your education
and as long as he believes that he's
going to be stuck where he is and so
it's the awareness right the awareness
that you're holding yourself back
because so many of these limiting
beliefs you just do unconsciously it's
subconscious you do it because it's
habit you do because you've always done
it and you don't even recognize that
it's a habit that is limiting and
destructive for you so step one is
recognizing what you're limiting beliefs
are and a good way to do it is answer
this question I can't achieve my goals
because what what is it what's that
thing that's there that's holding you
back that is it your lack of education
lack of resources not the right
connections what is it that's a living
and belief right there
and then what you wanted to try to catch
yourself in the moment try to catch
yourself the next time you find yourself
thinking that not afterwards not
afterwards what you say ah I should have
handled out a different way you have
that little regret because you didn't
you didn't take action the right way but
in the moment when you're experiencing
it right now this is a limiting belief
right now and then three have the guts
to actually change have the guts to do
it anyway right to be afraid of it and
do it anyway that's how you start
breaking your belief because you'll
realize that even though it's scary it's
not not being is not being scared cuz
it's been it being afraid and doing it
anyway we realize that by being scared
and conquering that fear the first time
becomes easier the next time an easier
the next time easier the next time so
that's the pattern and you want to break
as many of those beliefs as you can and
every single major growth that I've had
in my business has come from breaking
through a limiting personal belief so
one identify what it is right be
self-aware enough to identify it to try
to figure it out in the moment when
you're experiencing it and three take
action in the moment even though you're
afraid to do the opposite of what you
normally would do and conquer that limit
is believed so the question of a today
is what are your limiting beliefs give
you the biggest limiting beliefs you
have right now that is holding you where
you are instead of letting you grow to
where you want to be leaving the
comments below or join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
i'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot a vinspresso
latest recipe me go